[Musica]
che ne pensi merlino tutti dicono che
strana che ha qualcosa che non va
a me sembra una bambola normalissima tu
che ne pensi
devo aprirla ma pro merlino se berlino
vuoi aprirla poiché la pro o stai
cercando di dirmi che non devo aprirla
ladro che c'è lì no qualcosa di strano
con questa bambola non so perché vuole
sempre tirarvi qualche zampata
vabbè chi se ne frega io la pro secondo
me solo una stupida bambola e merlino
ammette costanti topica questa favola e
cercando di morde la
[Musica]
spesso ma merlino non puoi distruggerla
questa vediamo un po come questa bambola
apriamola non mi guardare così mi sembra
una bambola normalissima
[Musica]
il re dimenticate che parlava più
staccato un braccio per sbaglio o marzo
solo che non l'ho fatto apposta si è
staccato come stavo cercando di tirarla
fuori
va beh ma tanto ma è solo una bambola
perché mi sto preoccupando ho letto
troppe cose strane ora mi sto facendo
influenzare ecco fatto mi dispiace per
il braccio non so se riesco ad
aggiustarlo beh mi sembra una bambola
normalissima tu che dici berlino è una
bambola normalissima tranne il fatto che
si ha il braccio a penzoloni
ma se riesco ad aggiustarlo vediamo
proporrei attaccarlo ogni tanto mi
dimentico che parla e mi spaventa ok
forse sono riuscita riattaccarlo mi
sembra che si muova ok sono riuscita ad
arrestarlo bene quindi cosa dovrebbe
avere che non va questa bambola giochi
non si chiudono nemmeno tranne il fatto
che parla ma ci sono un sacco di bambole
che parlano nei negozi beh berlino tu
che ne pensi
a me sembra una stupida bambola
normalissima berlino non si morte perché
vuoi distruggere la poverina e non ad
una così carina non capisco perché
merlino ce l'ha proprio con questa
bambola niente merlino andiamo e non
solo perdere tempo con questi giocattoli
andiamo
[Musica]
no ha detto non puoi trovarla che stavi
facendo si può sapere perché ce l'hai
contro questa bambola guarda e una dopo
una normalissima titolato famiglia
preferisce così giochiamo insieme
andiamo
beh vediamo un bambino ti amo qual è
meglio che chiudo la porta altrimenti so
che rientri per estrarre occhietti la
bambola
[Musica]
no
c'è chi
[Musica]
che cosa ci fa
nemmeno deve averlo portato qua
[Musica]
aspetta un momento
come ha fatto male non prenderlo se
c'era la porta chiusa
[Musica]
ora ti tolgo la dote di così smetti ti
ridere si apre
a
[Musica]
le batterie